[Music]
all right miss Caitlin hey we are in
Napa Valley my Disneyland why do you
love coming back to Napa
do I have to even say why this stuff
that stuff is rosy and it was
free-flowing all weekend at sterling
vineyards oh I appreciate you is Rosie
your drink what is your go-to uh red
white and rosy et was exclusively with
the former Bachelorette in wine country
she said she and fiancé Sean booth will
definitely tie the knot there the only
question is when have you guys gotten
any closer to setting a date nope it's
not that we don't talk about it we just
haven't set a date and also I just feel
like I don't have time to get married
right now no time busy woman
would you consider a low fee do we need
to get shot on a plane here well you're
already here do consider eloping
actually all the time yeah yeah like
when we were in Hawaii last like should
we just do it
I mean what's stopping you I always go
back and forth like a year ago I was
like I want a big wedding and when we
know we'll just decide and we'll throw
it together but it is not gonna be like
your traditional wedding I want like a
funky dress I just wanted to be a big
fun party when you say a funky dress do
you mean color Rose a color bluffing
like this yeah Oh that'll be so stunning
and so you goofy sexy both multiple
dresses yep bring it on and get this
Kaitlyn's nuptials would have a royal
tie-in you recently did such a
breathtaking photo shoot you got to work
with Megan Markel's bestie no big deal
just Mulrooney yeah and she styled you
what was that experience like I got to
try on all these gorgeous wedding
dresses and yeah we had a great time
Shawn was part of this shoe yes what was
his reaction when he saw you looking
like a breathtaking bride he's like well
when it's the real date day I'm gonna be
emotional he goes but it's just like
I've seen you do 10 photo shoots with
wedding dresses I would have teared up
cuz I think you're so beautiful
I mean some people did but not Sean not
sure is Jessica someone your
considering having style you for your
wedding yeah out of the photo so you
don't like oh you're good you you're
good yeah
from bride to boss not only is Caitlin
busy hosting her off the vine podcast
and working on creating her own wine
she also exclusively revealed her latest
business venture to ET I'm bringing the
90s back with a scrunchy line no you're
not oh yeah I am
yeah I have rock scrunchies almost every
day and I'm like wait I need to do my
own line we're gonna get like a few
colors going we're just gonna get it out
there and then just you know I want to
listen to what people want yeah and
their feedback and go from of you I got
a lot of [ __ ] hair I got a lot of things
that I need I've got a lot of extensions
[Music]
[Applause]